welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
titled the opioid epidemic in Ohio a
crime laboratory perspective it's my
pleasure to introduce to you our keynote
douglas erode douglas has been employed
by the Lake County Crime Laboratory Ohio
since January 2000 and as the supervisor
of chemistry and toxicology he holds a
bachelor's of science and chemistry from
Gannon University and a Masters of
Science and chemistry clinical from
Cleveland State University for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab located at the
top of your screen
my name is Xavier good stairs and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots leverage is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming mr. Douglas Road I
will now turn the presentation over to
him hello my name is Douglas rody
I'm the supervisor of chemistry and
toxicology at the Lake County Crime
Laboratory it's a privilege to present
for elaborate skhul Diagnostics virtual
events I am including a conflict of
interest statement I have no conflicts
of interest with any commercial or
financial relationships so where is Lake
County Ohio Lake County is to the east
of Cleveland on Lake Erie
in the Northeast Ohio area you can see
this on the map we are proximate to
Pennsylvania to the east West Virginia
Kentucky to the south Indiana and
Michigan to the west our laboratory is a
smaller crime laboratory and we employ
approximately 15 people in the drug
chemistry and toxicology section I have
three people employed my talk today is
going to be about the opioid epidemic
and I will be talking about some of the
history of how this all started
what exactly are opiates versus opioids
some of the pharmacology involved and
then the trends were seeing and then I'm
going to finish the presentation with
testing items such as
amine alysus and confirmatory testing so
in 2015 the Washington Post had an
article where opiates killed the most
people in 2015 and you can see on this
map as the states are shaded darker it
indicates a greater concentration of
deaths due to opioids on the left as the
heroin deaths in 2015 on the right
opioid deaths you can see there was a
concentration in the Midwest here with
Ohio West Virginia and Kentucky and that
trend has remained stable throughout
2019 blocks did an article regarding the
opioid epidemic and it stated it's
America's worst drug crisis ever I've
been doing toxicology testing since 1983
so I did live through the cocaine
epidemic in the 80s and then the
methamphetamine epidemic and I agree
this particular epidemic of opioids is
far greater in the number of deaths and
applications for hails and then anything
before you can see I'm gonna go back a
slide at the end of this article the
last sentence preliminary data we have
from 2016 suggests that the epidemic may
have gotten worse since 2015 and indeed
that was true especially in Ohio this is
from the Centers for Disease Control and
you can see how opioid-related overdoses
deaths rose nationwide versus what
happened in Ohio there was a precipitous
rise from 2015 to 2016 and then this
chart if you take it further out the
rise continues both nationally in the
Ohio so when did we first start noticing
a problem in 2010 and I'm going to speak
predominantly about the Cleveland area
and Ohio but this is true nationally to
some extent as well there are pockets of
opioid there opioid centers that are
worse than others obviously based on the
church that I've showed the maps Ohio
West Virginia Kentucky is a particularly
bad hit area and then in the West some
states haven't even experienced an
opioid epidemic at all so there was an
increase starting in 2010 with a number
of opioid deaths in the Cleveland area
and the surrounding suburbs 77% in
Cleveland proper and then 176 percent in
the surrounding suburbs the sale of
opioids credible in the last 15 years
and it's interesting to note in the
United States consumes 80% of the global
supply health care insurance claims
followed suit with opioid dependence
claims the
those increased 3,000 percent and then
opioid deaths exceeded 18,000 a year due
to heroin they would interview heroin
users and 90 percent greater than 90
percent of these individuals had stated
they had switched to heroin because it
was cheaper and easier to obtain than
some of the prescription opioids such as
oxycodone there was a federal act the
comprehensive addiction and Recovery Act
signed by President Obama in 2016 which
did bring national attention to the
problem and it is drug overdose by FAR's
now the leading cause of accidental
death in the United States so the first
exposure so to speak of opioids we've
all been quote exposed to opioids
through a classic movie and you can see
here the Wizard of Oz there's a
particular scene where Dorothy and a
crew are trying to get to the Emerald
City and they have to cross a field of
poppies and Dorothy falls asleep and the
movie the antidote was snow and if that
were true if that worked
then perhaps we wouldn't have such a
problem here in the Cleveland area
especially this time of year however as
you know that was just a movie
presentation and the antidote or the
recovery for an opioid overdose is
narcan we'll be talking about that a
little bit later the opium poppy has
been in existence for quite some time
3200 BC there's a notation of puppies
being grown in the Mesopotamia area and
you can see in the bottom right photo
the collection
the sap or milk for the poppy like
scouring the poppy pod and you can see
the SAP coming out and then that is
collected so there is some confusion
then it still exists today over the
definitions opiates versus opioids and
opiates refer only to the alkaloids that
are found in the opium poppy and such as
morphine codeine papaverine NZ babe
opioids is an umbrella type term the
covers not only the opiates but the semi
synthetics like heroine and then the
synthetic opioids such as fentanyl there
is a term used and bandied about quite a
bit in our colleagues and some people
will refer to the opioids as narcotics
but really narcotics is a term covering
that only opioids but drugs of abuse and
illicit drugs in general so what do hope
you always do we all know this
especially those of you in the clinical
arena it's designed for relief of pain
and severe pain is used in preparations
for suppression of cough or an anti
diarrheal medication and of course the
epidemic primarily is due to the fact
that opioid abuse can cause euphoria or
will cause you foria you can develop
tolerance and then you can also have
dependence on opioids it goes without
saying that the opioid drug is highly
addictive it is not unusual to have
drivers and what I do at the crime lab
is predominantly toxicology testing
regarding impaired drivers and also some
work for the coroner and one of the
telltale
an opioid overdose the driver or someone
found unconscious is pinpoint pupils the
this is the sign that's law enforcement
officers will use and dr e's will use to
determine whether someone knows under
the effect of opioids you will have CNS
depression and of course respiratory
depression and pulmonary edema
respiratory depression is a telltale
sign as well
slowed breathing agonal breathing and
then eventually if you have enough of an
opioid or several opioids in your system
the respiratory center will cease to
function and that leads to death the
opioid receptors are primarily located
in the brain and spinal cord but they're
really spread throughout the body the
effects of opioids depends on the types
of receptor receptors which are bound
and where the receptors are located in
the body there are three primary opioid
receptors and Delta Kappa and mu are
those receptors many people have heard
about the mule receptor but there are
others as well
this slide is a little busy but I wanted
to show which receptor was responsible
for which effect of the opioids you can
see that pain relief is linked to
several of the receptors pupil
constriction and the mule receptor is
primarily the receptor responsible for
the euphoric effect of opioids
if you go down to the bottom of the
slide second to the last sentence
euphoria is a result of the dopamine
release and neurotransmission is the
cause of a runner's high so those of you
who are athletic and run you may have
felt the euphoria that you hit after you
hit the the brick wall and then you feel
better this is a dopamine release all
opiate receptors all forms of the opiate
receptors can be found in the brain also
the spine
spinal cord digestive tract this slide
emphasizes the fact that one of the
major effects of opioids is to inhibit
pain and the neurotransmitter release is
inhibited and that will also inhibit the
conduction of the pain impulse and here
is a picture of that neuro transmitter
and the synaptic cleft and how there's a
block of the release of the
neurotransmitter there is a part of the
brain and it's called the nucleus
accumbens and this is where your reward
system is located the pleasure center of
the brain and you can have receptor
stimulation in the nucleus accumbens
resulting in impulses leaving the
because they're cummins and activating
the reward system this is the phoric
effect which is felt so here we see not
only the release or I'm sorry the relief
of pain but also
the activation of the pleasure center to
the major effects of opioids the opioid
antagonist which most people are
familiar with is naloxone commonly known
as narcan this is a short-acting
antidote the half-life is one to two
hours when an individual is pulled over
or detected on the road and the are
suspected to be under the influence of
opioids naloxone is often given and
depending on the response to the
naloxone that will depend on how many
doses are administered when the opioid
epidemic started several years ago and
the police narratives I would know that
there would be one to two doses of
naloxone given in a heroin overdose as
the potency of the opioids increased we
started seeing fentanyl and some of the
fentanyl works
the amount of naloxone that was required
to block the opioid binding to the
receptors increased and there is a there
was a report from the Highway Patrol and
this was probably two years ago that
they had one traffic stop where they
administered 16 to 18 doses of naloxone
to a driver now since that time that
record may have been broken because we
have consistently and continually seen
more potent opioids one of which I will
be talking about later in this
presentation now truck soon is another
opioid antagonist it's longer acting the
half-life of 11 hours and it's designed
to guard against placing a person into
opioid withdrawal so in the case of the
emergency response naloxone is given
repeatedly until the individual is
transported to a hospital or medical
facility where it can be given either IV
or continued to get to be administered
until the amount of opioid that's
president and the person system is
diminished there is tolerance to opioids
and this is also part of the epidemic
that we're seeing and it's amazing it's
an amazing thing I never believed it
possible that the human body could be so
tolerant to opioids and we've seen in
extreme cases the most potent opioid
we've encountered his car fentanyl and
we have noted that people have built a
tolerance to this drug I'll be talking
about car fentanyl a little bit later
but it is designed as a large animal
tranquilizer
certainly not for human consumption yet
people are taking it and they're taking
it along with other opioids so there is
a great deal of Tolerance that can be
built up to opioids one of the dangers
of this is that if a person goes into
treatment or jail and then they are
absent opioids for a period of a week or
two or longer and then they go back out
on the streets or back home and resume
their opioid use there is a tendency for
these individuals to return to the same
dose that they had used prior to their
incarceration or their treatment and you
will lose your opioid tolerance over
time and that
is a cause of many opioid overdoses and
deaths simply people who have lost the
tolerance and don't know that they've
lost it and they return to the dose that
they were used to one thing I wanted to
emphasize in this slide as well
regardless of the tolerance that will be
developed with individuals you will
still have pinpoint pupils and that's
still an outward sign where clinicians
or law enforcement will receive a hint
that someone is under the influence of
opioids so I'm gonna go through some of
the opioids that we know about and I'm
going to also transition into some of
the new fentanyl analogues you may not
have heard of yet so it all started with
morphine and morphine is nothing new
this was extracted over 200 years ago
morphine was named that for after
morpheus the god of dreams
it's interesting to note this is the
prototypical opioid and which potency is
measured so whenever a new analog
fentanyl analog our opioid emerges the
potency will be compared to working
after morphine then there was a
development of heroin and this was
synthesized in 1874 if you are a history
buff you know that a few years before
that was a major event in our country a
civil war and what had happened was the
veterans were suffering with a great
deal of pain because back then medical
care obviously wasn't like it was now
there were many amputations
and the physicians then noticed that
these veterans were becoming addicted to
morphine so there was an attempt to
chemically alter the morphine to make it
less addictive and through a set elation
they created heroin and heroin was
supposed to be was designed to be a safe
a safer alternative to morphine
it is a Schedule one drug and you know
in the United States we have five
scheduled schedule one being a drug with
little to no medical benefit and high
addictive potential and there are a
handful of drugs in the schedule heroin
being one of them there are two forms
the salt form the hydrochloride salt
form and the classical heroin which has
been in existence for some time is
usually a beige hand color but it can be
white and then there's a freebase form
where you would have black tar heroin
interestingly enough the black tar
heroin at least in Lake County and Ohio
disappeared for some time but lately
we've seen it return at some of the
evidence submissions we've had and that
requires heating to liquify it so that
you can inject it through IV injection
or vaporization another interesting
property of heroin is that it is a very
fast metabolizer
the half-life of heroin is three to six
minutes which is extremely rapid for any
drug and you will not detect heroin in a
toxicology screen or conformation unless
the sample is drawn within that small
time frame but you will oftentimes see
six mono acetyl
or 6:00 a.m. this is a marker which is
definitive or heroine and it is screened
for oftentimes in the urine because it
will be present for a longer amount of
time here's a little bit of organic
chemistry for those who are chemistry
majors then you can see heroin at the
top with the acetyl groups to either
side and the first metabolite you'll see
just the ones the subtle group instead
of two one one is removed and then the
second one is removed go back to
morphine I described this when I go to
court in front of juries the heroin is
like a Mickey Mouse hat and everyone can
envision that and that the ears are the
subtle groups and if you break off one
year you have a Mickey Mouse hat with
one ear that is six - you know more
thing in there than a few subsequently
break off the other ear and just have
the cap without ears that is working
oxycodone is a semi-synthetic opioid and
that was synthesized over a hundred
years ago nothing new it has been around
and it is a schedule 2 drug meaning
there is obviously medicinal use or this
drug it was created once again as an
alternative to morphine and you can
obtain this either as an immediate
release or a controlled release which is
oxycontin and the oxymorphone metabolite
was discovered to be about ten times
more potent than the parent oxycodone
there was a reformulation about a decade
ago which precipitated the abuse of
oxymorphone
or opana this was a particularly West
Virginia was particularly hard hit by
opana in one particular town there were
I forget him the percentage of the
population of this town was addicted to
oxy more and then we come to fentanyl
which is getting all the attention now
and rightfully so
it's an eighty to a hundred times more
potent than morphine
there are several derivatives of
fentanyl you can see the the last
analogue there is car fentanyl a large
animal tranquilizer
fentanyl once again has been around for
a while and I remember when I worked at
the Cleveland Clinic Foundation
there were fentanyl patches and fentanyl
patch abuse there was known only abuse
from patients but also from some of the
staff as well unfortunately the abuse of
transdermal patches was a problem for
quite some time I'm not sure anymore if
that's a common occurrence or not but
working not only in a clinical
laboratory but also forensic laboratory
and at one time I worked for a coroner
there were occasions where people would
have several fentanyl patches all over
their body it was quite a sight to see
fentanyl of course is used quite a bit
in the distant either in hospice care
surgery at all for pain relief
the new form is essentially a powder and
it is purchased
illicitly distributed illicitly it has
the appearance of other narcotics and
and I want to emphasize that with these
new forms of opioids they all look the
same they're all a white powder or tan
or they can be multiple colors as well
we've seen blue green just any kind of
color there's no way you can look at a
powder and then we do this in the crime
lab for our drug identification there's
no way you can tell when you have a
white powder or whether that is
methamphetamine perhaps or cocaine or
fentanyl or fentanyl analogue some
fentanyl analogue you just can't tell by
looking at it and that requires a
testing at the molecular level for
identification on the right is a small
the picture on the right shows the small
amount that would be considered a lethal
dose if it was injected into the body
just a few grains of fentanyl can't be
lethal here's a slide that shows the
impact of fentanyl in Ohio from 2012 to
2015 I used the term skyrocket quite a
bit for interviews that I gave about the
fentanyl epidemic in our region and in
Ohio you can see how many deaths or
overdoses we had a short amount of time
they just went up so high in such a
short amount of time it was incredible
to take note of the
try to track it and they still
defensible deaths still rose the next
year the next year after that I wanted
to provide some therapeutic toxic and
lethal levels for comparison and
morphine at the top your therapeutic is
less than or equal to 100 nanograms per
ml then you drop down to fentanyl and
you can see it's 1 2 3 nanograms per ml
non oxycodone oxymorphone hydrocodone
there in that mix so the amount of the
drug that is needed to achieve the
effect of morphine is considerably less
and it's not unusual to have barely
enough to even weigh just have residue
in the submitted evidence which could
turn out to be deadly to the individual
so I wanted to talk about one particular
opioid that showed up in Ohio in 2016
this was you for 7700 now this is not a
fentanyl analogue it's correctly
classified as an opioid and Ohio was
very aggressive when this showed up in
Ohio and we had a number of deaths the
legislatures in Ohio acted very quickly
to schedule this drug to try to mitigate
its effect within the state and
penalized those who were using and
distributing it so the first fatality of
you for 7700 was in my County Lake
County and this is why I'm partly why
I'm presenting
because I have first-hand knowledge of
this in January 2016 we had a young man
in his 20s who was living with his
parents was found dead on the floor of
his bedroom and although we don't do the
high-end toxicology testing that
reference labs or post-mortem labs will
do we do as much as we can in the crime
lab with screening and then one thing
that is particularly unique about my
crime lab because it is small is that
not only do I see the toxicology results
i I also supervise the drug chemistry so
I'm able to see what is happening on the
streets and there is a lag time between
those opioids that are detected in
powders that are confiscated and
submitted to the crime lab versus the
detection in the toxicology sample
there's approximately six months or
longer lag time where there used to be
at this point so the coroner would when
he had a suspect opioid death would
collect all the paraphernalia found at
the death scene and submitted to the
crime lab so we could immediately do
analysis of the syringe and the powder
and let him know what we had found so he
could in turn either compare that the
subsequent toxicology results which
takes some time or inform the toxicology
laboratory that this was what was found
proximate to the body this was a picture
of the death scene and on the lower left
you could see the body of the young man
where the blue arrow is pointing is
where the drug paraphernalia was found
this is the evidence that was recovered
there was a substantial amount of white
powder found in a rolled-up $10 bill I
understand in this picture that $10 bill
was flattened that it became flattened
and transportation from the crime scene
to the laboratory but at the time the
officers recovered it it was rolled up
and once again note the appearance of
the powder it is a white powder this
looks somewhat fluffy for lack of a
better term and looking at it there's no
way any forensic chemist could tell by
appearance exactly what that powder is
or if it's one drug or several drugs
contained within a chemical
identification but once again this is a
list of evidence found in the vicinity
of the decedent the white powder of the
rolled-up $10 bill there was a paperback
book with powder residue which was the
platform the decedent used we suspect to
used to ingest this powder or snort it
there was a dropper bottle with an
unknown liquid and then an e-cigarette
was found in a crime lab some of the
common tools used for chemical
examination are gas chromatography and
mass spectrometry and FTIR Fourier
transform infrared spectroscopy the
e-cigarette the contents were identified
as nicotine and then everything else
contained an unknown substance meaning
that what we had analyzed was never seen
in our laboratory before we had
library entry for the resulting spectra
on the GCMs
it was totally unknown to us so what are
the tools in a crime lab that can be
used for identification all crime labs
will have an in-house mass spectral
library there are commercial libraries
and under libraries which can be
utilized as well and then if that
doesn't work you start making phone
calls there is a good network of drug
chemists within Ohio we were all
battling this at the same time and it's
common for the drug chemists to call one
another to see if this particular drug
was seen in a different area of the
state drug abuse is very regional in our
state we have found and it holds true
with this opioid epidemic as well
meaning that an northern part of the
state in the Cleveland area we would see
drugs that they weren't seeing in the
southern part of the state which would
be Cincinnati Dayton and then conversely
they would identify drugs that we hadn't
seen yet there is a group of drug
chemists that focus only on clandestine
laboratories and I sought out their
assistants as well there's a great
network of forensic toxicologist in the
United States I have found I have been
involved with the forensic toxicology
field for some time now and these
scientists are eager to help one another
or you just give a phone call or an
email and I did that with several of my
colleagues to find out if they had seen
this unknown drug and then beyond the
borders of the United States there's an
international group of forensic
toxicologist which can be contacted as
well and there was a not necessarily
last resort but if you have enough time
and knowledge you can look at the
spectra for interpretation and then look
at the undo structural' elucidation that
is time-consuming and often times drug
chemists don't don't have the luxury of
time so they'll use some of these other
avenues as I did my first indication of
what I had was an international
toxicology warning system rebuilds an
early warning system on drugs or the
scientific Institute of Public Health
reported in February 2016 about a
fatality involving the new word opioid
you for 7700 remember my death was kind
of in the middle of January of 2016 and
this was my first knowledge or
indication that there was a new opioid
present in the drug stream and then they
listed what type of open way this was
the potency and what the action and much
like working and then go back a slide so
this gave me an occassion of what it was
but that's not enough information for me
to definitively identify when I have an
unknown
I need a spectral match to what I have
and that was provided by a colleague and
Dallas Texas doctor Spargo who had
published an article in tox talk which
is distributed to forensic toxicologist
in the United States and and beyond and
you can see in the right hand corner
this was a March April edition
and this was my first indication of a
spectral match to my unknown so at this
point I had suspected I had you for 7700
now I knew for sure that this is what I
had interestingly enough one of my
colleagues in Lorain County which is on
the other side of Cleveland Lake County
is on the eastern side of Cleveland
Lorain County side the western side they
had encountered an unknown drug which
turned out to be you for 7700 in
February so this drug had hit in Ohio
and it was showing up and in the
Northeast Ohio area and each of us was
trying to figure out what what this was
this particular formulation of the drug
wasn't a powder but it was a clandestine
fake oxycodone tablet which did not
contain oxycodone but contained the
contained at you for seven seven zero
zero so the toxicology the initial
report from February indicated the
presence of presumptive positive for
benzos and cannabinoids by immunoassay
and then a confirmatory result of the
marijuana metabolites in the blood was
that enough to explain the death was
that providing an identification of the
unknown powder no it wasn't so by the
time I had identified what this powder
was and we had notified the toxicology
laboratory in March we had found out
that this laboratory was working on an
assay at that moment to identify newer
synthetic opioids and one of those
opioids was you for 7700 so all of this
was occurring essentially at the same
time in the
the winter of 2016 so once that
toxicology laboratory had worked up and
validated their assay they issued a
secondary report which identified the
unknown substance and the decedent's of
blood as you four seven seven zero zero
which correlated to my identification of
the powder and it was at a lethal level
two hundred and forty two and a grams
per ml coroner ruled the manner of death
has accidental cause of death as you
four seven seven zero zero toxicity some
of the demographics in the area
indicate that and this was the Northeast
Ohio area interestingly the age of the
abusers were twenty seven to forty nine
gender mostly male marital status
married single and unknown race
predominantly white all of these
individuals had a history of past opioid
abuse so they were trying a new opioid
here's where the legislation I'm sorry
the legislatures in Ohio took action and
our governor at the time John Kasich
issued an executive order 2016 oh one K
dealing with the synthetic opioid known
as you four seven seven zero he put it
into the schedule one category and this
was on May 3rd 2016 so the decedent in
like Emily died in the middle of January
and three months later or four months
later the drug had become scheduled
it's an incredibly it was an incredibly
fast process to do such a scheduling
this even got the attention of the Wall
Street Journal and they wrote up an
article about
the u4 7700 on how Ohio is so aggressive
in scheduling us and trying to control
it but even though we felt good about
what had happened we had no idea what
was coming next and we got hit very bad
in Ohio especially once again in the
Northeast Ohio area with a number of
unexplained deaths they all happened in
Summit County which that's where Akron
is south of Cleveland 52 unexplained
deaths in one month and I believe in one
weekend there were 16 or 18 deaths
totally baffling to the medical examiner
and the forensic toxicologist there it
turned out to be car fentanyl and you
have probably no doubt heard of the
spread of car fentanyl or how potent it
really is and that's what had happened
car pencil had hit Ohio we were unaware
and in order to get a car fence a little
standard and remember this is a large
animal tranquilizer not really available
commercially to any laboratory we all
had to go to our local zoos to get a car
fentanyl sample to compare to this
unknown drug here is a potency chart and
car fence at all you can see in relation
to fentanyl how potent it is and that's
arrow is pointing to zoo workers
tranquilizing a zebra with car fentanyl
so it has turned out to be the mother of
all sentinels and I say so far because
there are potentially 1,400 sentinels or
more that have been either designed or
synthesized and some of them have a
potency greater than car fentanyl
fortunately we haven't seen those yet in
the
lower box the paragraph last line in
2017 in the United States there were 451
of cars fence in all cases and of those
451 identifications 83 percent or in
Ohio so we were hit very hard and in
this region this is a submission in our
one of our agencies in Lake County of 13
grams of car fentanyl it only takes a
few grains to cause death so you can
imagine the potential for 13 grams how
many people could die from that amount
of car fentanyl but now we're dealing
not only with car comes a little but
several other fentanyl analogues and
it's part of the opioid tsunami the
tsunami continues and the opioids and
the analogues change but we're still
having still having to deal with this
tsunami on a daily basis this slide I
apologize it's it's small in print but
it is the opioid caseload in my
laboratory the numbers aren't
particularly large in comparison to a
state lab of what I want to emphasize is
the trend of the particular drugs and
then by a year so you can see heroin on
our first the first line is heroin it
really peaked in 2016 and has declined
since then fentanyl peaked in 2016 it
has it dipped a little bit and then when
up in 2018 the you for 7700 was
President 26 20 2016 2017
essentially disappeared for a while but
notice in the difference between 2016
and 2017 how many new fentanyl analogues
we had detected and then between 2017
and 2018 so every year we will have a
whole slew of new fentanyl analogs
unknown to us which are present in the
submitted evidence that we get car
fentanyl just a note it showed up in
2016 it really peaked for us in 2017 and
then diminished but then by the by the
end of last year it had gone dormant we
didn't have a case for several months
but at the beginning of 2019 car
fentanyl was back in the drug stream in
the drugs in Lake County and also in all
of Ohio so we're peaking again with car
Sentinel I'm going to go through these
relatively quickly but you can see these
are examples of submissions to our
laboratory and when we talk about these
fentanyl analogs it's not just one or
two that are showing up in drug
paraphernalia it could be as many as
five six eight sometimes ten so it's not
unusual for us to get pieces of straws
paper folds containing powder and then
it will contain several different
analogs and opioids and you can see you
know imagine ingesting that amount of
Sentinel analogs and trying to figure
out the potency of each one and how in
combination with one or the other how
the human body deals with that and once
again I'm amazed at the tolerance that
individuals have to all of these
fentanyl analogs
here's another example this was a spoon
and a needle containing brown liquid
which was blood of course and not only
did you have car fence at all but a
whole slew of other than all the
analogues in the syringe there's a
syringe of the needle six seven
different uh ethanol analogues plus
heroin here's another example this was a
syringe or the needle just just
incredible the amount of fentanyl
analogues that can be seen interestingly
in this one you'll notice towards the
bottom there's cocaine cocaine and
methamphetamine I have have risen up
again as drugs of abuse they were lower
for a while but now they're coming back
into vogue so to speak and then also
clandestine pills where they purport to
be oxycodone but they contain that's why
we analogues and the professionalism of
these clandestine tablets is amazing my
visualization by trained drug chemist we
can't tell the difference between
pharmaceutically prepared tablets and
the clandestine tablets they look
identical I'm going to go through these
relatively quickly these are reports of
fentanyl fentanyl analogues throughout
the United States
this fentanyl in 2017 and you can see
depending on where you live how fentanyl
is affecting that state this is car
fentanyl of course Ohio stands out in
each one of these slides
this is acetyl fentanyl Akron fentanyl
per animal fentanyl three methyl
fentanyl
cyclopropyl fentanyl and then you for
7700 we tried our best in Ohio to try to
diminish it but we still were
unfortunately the number one state that
had this drug in it so I want to finish
it
by just talking about clinical and
forensic laboratory testing we're all in
the same boat here analyzing the
fentanyl and fentanyl analogs is a real
challenge and when you're having to deal
with turnaround time in a clinical
laboratory or court time in a forensic
laboratory it's really quite a challenge
and we're both both disciplines are
facing the same challenge this picture
by the way I grabbed off of the
Wikipedia entry for Hospital
laboratories and I can see is kind of
all based on the computer monitors but
you get an idea this is a typical screen
instrument for a clinical lab
immunoassays is still the preferred and
quickest way to screen for drugs they've
been in existence for a very long time
at both clinical and forensic
laboratories but when you're dealing
with fentanyl it's it's a bit of a
problem there are cross reactivity
problems and then as these new analogs
which I've listed and shown in the
previous slides become present in the
drugs on the street and then
subsequently in the patient's the the
immunoassays probably won't pick them up
here is a chart of a comparison of
commercial kits there's nine separate
commercial kits for fentanyl
immunoassays and you can see the cross
reactivity if you have greater than 50%
it could be you have a green a good bar
moderate ten to fifty percent 10% low
and then the black part of the bar is
not tested percent of fentanyl analogues
not tested 59% providing references that
these are recent references from last
year regarding defense of all amino
acids if you are interested in further
reading about these and some of the
problems I would recommend getting of
all of these references another great
source that I utilize quite a bit as the
AACC artery and particularly the
toxicology threads this is one from
August and September of this year
talking about that's an alum you know
assays in particular specifically the
ones that are FDA approved and the
recommendations from a variety of
laboratories what they use what's good
and bad now because I work in a forensic
laboratory solely I have limited contact
with clinical labs although I still keep
my toes wet in the clinical realm and
will oftentimes visit the laboratories
in the Lake County area and also work
with our probation department that are
using some of these assays I would
encourage you if you are a member of a
ACC to jump on and look at the artery
and the discussions they're very useful
there's a point of care options and I
know some probation departments will use
the cups for screening but I am not
particularly impressed with those
because I've noted there are a fair
amount of false positives
when
these cups and always with fentanyl
urinalysis screen results the
interpretation must be done with extreme
caution because the negative result does
not necessarily mean you have no offense
at all and or a fentanyl analog you saw
the slide where I had how many analogues
could be present in one individual
syringe and that means all those
analogues will be present in the person
as well
you are not necessarily going to catch
them in a urinalysis screen so the
bottom line and many of the contributors
to the thread said physicians oftentimes
and rightfully so treat the patient
based on the clinical presentation
here's a few presentations it's a case
number one twenty three-year-old found
unresponsive in bed was given the lock
so admitted to the ICU and then
eventually discharged if you are using a
GC on this which was a high-end type of
instrumentation even in a clinical lab
you potentially could miss the opioids
and here on the left is the GCMs result
on the right is an LC time-of-flight ms
technique but LC ms/ms is commonly used
as well you can see the type of
instrumentation lends itself to greater
sensitivity and all these drugs that
were present that weren't picked up by
GCMs here's another presentation 17-year
old student before class would snorted
some powder was found unresponsive in
the car and a school nurse administer
naloxone patients adamantly refused
using opioids yet ultimately you for
7700 was found
in that powder this is my last slide and
I I want to provide a little bit of good
news here
the overdose deaths dropped last year in
Ohio and then there within the article
they know that that overdose deaths
decreased across the United States last
year in 2018 and that was noted as the
first drop in nearly three decades so
maybe maybe just maybe this tsunami is
subsiding and and we can get some relief
from the opioid epidemic it's not going
away anytime soon
our laboratory this year identified I
think four or five new Sentinel analogs
which we hadn't seen before so it's
still an issue but we're hopefully on
the tail end of I do want to acknowledge
my colleagues in Ohio and especially dr.
John Wyman he was the forensic
toxicologist at the Cleveland medical
examiner's office he provided so much
information to me and I appreciate his
knowledge and I consider him one of the
foremost experts in Ohio on opioids some
of these other people are my colleague
Steve perch is the one that had to deal
with the massive amount of car fentanyl
deaths in Akron and also I wanted to
acknowledge some of the people outside
of Ohio that I was able to utilize their
knowledge and expertise as well I do
have a slide with my contact information
however I understand that to you if you
have any questions they will be sent to
me through my email and I want to thank
you very much for letting me present to
you today Thank You Douglas for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank
average for making today's educational
webcast possible and as a final reminder
mister road will follow up with any
questions you submit it via email that's
all for now thank you for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye